Dr Bradshaw had only been working at the
SCP Foundation for a few years but in
that time he had seen things that had
changed him irreparably ancient texts
about world-ending Abominations machines
that could spontaneously produce any
food or drink from nowhere friendly
slime monsters with a penchant for
tickling invisible kleptomaniac women
and wannabe heroic men covered in spikes
but one anomaly in particular stuck with
him haunted his dreams and dominated his
waking thoughts
scp-049 that mysterious Mass doctor with
his deadly touch and strange beat Visage
trying in vain to cure something he
would only refer to as quote the
pestilence and quote the great dying his
cure was more like a curse it seemed as
his unusual treatments transformed his
patients into the Mindless Living Dead
shuffling around as malformed shells of
their former selves if this was The Cure
Dr Bradshaw found himself often
wondering what was the disease many
researchers had attempted to get to the
bottom of this question over the years
interviewing scp-049 and nurturing their
own pet theories in their free time but
none had ever received a satisfying
answer ever reached a real conclusion it
was this Legacy of fruitless
hypothesizing and questioning that led
Dr Bradshaw to pitch his own plan for
unmasking the pestilence once and for
all he would gather every prominent
Theory his colleagues could come up with
including several of his own then he
would simply engage the plague doctor in
polite discourse walking him through
each Theory one by one and waiting to
see if any of them stuck it took Dr
Bradshaw weeks to collect and distill
the theories down into a workable list
of questions consolidating those that
overlapped and eliminating those that
were simply ridiculous such as Dr
Bright's potentially facetious
insistence that the pestilence was
lactose intolerance but when the day
came he felt ready to take on the task
when the interview was through perhaps
he would have managed to do what none
before him at the foundation had perhaps
he would understand what the plague
doctor was fighting with his unorthodox
methods and by extension how they could
pacify him non-lethally once and for all
Dr Bradshaw held his notebook tight as
he made the long walk down the hall from
his office to
scp-049's containment chamber this was
it the Moment of Truth he hoped he had
asked his colleagues to pump the scent
of lavender in 2049's room to put him at
ease as well as give him his dinner just
in time for the meeting he hoped that
the meal a little glass of wine and the
peaceful atmosphere would make the
plague doctor more amenable to his line
of questioning
scp-049 was sitting in front of the wide
glass window fork and knife in hand when
Dr Bradshaw arrived hello doctor
Bradshaw gave zero four nine away ah
good evening they told me I would be
having company for dinner but where's
your food sir oh I'm I'm not hungry Dr
Bradshaw brushed him off politely no
sense it would be horribly rude for me
to eat well you have nothing excuse me
he called to a Garden nearby please
bring this man a helping of what you've
served me so we may dine together with
aside Dr Bradshaw nodded at the guard
giving him permission to do what the
plague doctor asked a few moments later
he too had a tray with a plate of fish
and roasted vegetables and a small cup
of wine on the side now may I ask you
some questions the plague doctor nodded
indeed what is it that I can do for you
I was hoping you could teach me more
about the pestilence Dr Bradshaw began
delicately the plague doctor perked up
have you come to assist me with my work
my dear fellow why did you not say so
from the start it would be my honor to
provide you with all the knowledge I
possess on this subject if you intend to
lend a hand I just want to understand
more about it first Dr Bradshaw said it
wasn't quite a lie not really he did
want to understand he flipped open his
notebook scanning the page for the first
of the positive theories he had gathered
is it possible that what you refer to
the pestilence you're talking about pain
as a whole the plague doctor cocked his
head to the side oh what do you mean
well you once described scp-096 as being
Afflicted with an extreme case of the
pestilence I believe and when you cure
someone they're no longer able to feel
any pain physical or emotional I know
that you mean well but is it possible
that's what you're trying to treat the
pain that naturally afflicts all human
life most living things the plague
doctor scoffed you think that I a
physician namso ignorant of pain and I
would mistake those agonies as something
so devastating a secret dying if you are
here to to insult me sir I will simply
ask that you leave I'm sorry that was
not my intention please let me stay I
promise I'm only here to try and
understand will you withhold judgment
until I'm finished one man of science to
another the plague doctor paused mulling
this over he nodded I will hear your
questions and do my best to answer them
thank you Dr Bradshaw smiled and
returned to his notes so you have been
in the field of medicine for quite some
time and I imagine you've studied a
variety of Sciences you work with a lot
of liquids and substances none of us
have ever encountered before were they
the result of alchemy used to balance
the humors of your patients I was
curious if your treatments and if the
pestilence itself is thermaturgical in
nature that is to say well magical the
plague doctor let out a sharp laugh at
this magic
so I am no magician nor am I an
alchemist as I have never formally
studied Alchemy in any form the humans
of course must be balanced for proper
Health but that has nothing to do with
Alchemy in my opinion how is your black
vial you appear to have an excess of it
do you experience a great deal of
stomach pain Dr Bradshaw rushed to steer
the topic away from him and his Health
Plus the plague doctor offered to treat
him not particularly next question his
eyes returned to his notes let's see
we've noticed that you seem to cure
those who are most afraid of death and
dying and when you first arrived at our
facility you stated that there was less
pestilence here than other places you
had been most of our staff have seen
enough death and Misfortune that it no
longer frightens us we're inoculated
against it essentially one researcher
working with you was afraid of death at
first but as he came to accept it as an
inevitability you said that he was no
longer infected is the pestilence fear
itself or more specifically the fear of
death the plague doctor mulled this over
one's ad look one's attitude can impact
their health it is easier to fight a
disease when one does not let fear take
over but other than that I'm afraid I do
not understand your question the
pestilence is simply what it is why are
you more preoccupied with categorizing
it than curing it I believe that to
understand something is to know how to
fight it Dr Bradshaw answered simply
we may differ there but you may continue
I'm grateful for the company and for
your desire to understand
misguided though it may be thank you
doctor I wanted to ask you are you
familiar with the Scarlet King the
plague doctor's expression did not
change I have seen the rise and fall of
many monarchs in my time why would you
ask me about this Scarlet King that
wasn't a noun well Dr Bradshaw began
according to Legend one of his many
daughters was pestilence a bringer of
disease and destruction is she the one
you intend to fight I know not every
single forms a pestilence takes only the
grip it has on this world
scp-049 answered for your sake I would
advise you to avoid speaking of such
matters that king is not a thing you
wish to face Dr Bradshaw jotted down a
quick note in the margin of the page
Scarlet King connection possible then he
returned to his line of questioning have
you spoken with scp-343 a HEV the plague
doctor nodded and what did he tell you
it is not worth going into here
according to him the pestilence that you
refer to as Humanity's free will you are
changed by something a long time ago a
tragedy that turned you towards your
work you came from a dark place one of
the places even 343 can see is that true
I will not answer that question it is an
insult as cp049 said again not a no
exactly but still Dr Bradshaw did not
want to push too hard too soon and risk
the doctor terminating their
conversation my apologies I'll shift to
something different you once treated the
Bubonic plague correct
scp-049 shook his head no I am not
familiar with that particular condition
Dr Bradshaw had prepared for this he
pulled the medical illustration from his
notebook depicting the victim of the
black plague uh what about something
like this SC zero four nine side ah now
this element I have encountered before I
did my best to treat it but it was
stubborn is it related to the pestilence
Dr Bradshaw asked not necessarily zero
four nine said nothing more than that he
took a sip of wine ate a bite of potato
he wasn't going to offer any more
insight into that particular Theory it
seemed I mean no offense with this next
question but doctor have you always
lived here on this planet or did you
make your way here from another world of
some kind perhaps the pestilence came
from wherever you did see what this
change I'll have me a great deal in my
life
scp-049 said but I have always been here
at least as best as I can recall he
seemed to be telling the truth but with
that unmoving inscrucible expression it
was difficult to be sure this next
Theory would be extremely difficult to
float without offending 049 but Dr
Bradshaw had to try he needed to do his
due diligence are you familiar with the
story of Typhoid Mary he would ease into
the idea that would probably be best I
am not
scp-049 sounded puzzled she was an
asymptomatic carrier of typhoid Dr
Bradshaw explained as others grew sick
around her she remained healthy and well
she had no idea that as she worked as a
cook in the houses of wealthy families
she was infecting them with a deadly
disease it was not any moral failing of
her own she didn't understand what she
was doing but she still spread the virus
throughout her community
the plague doctor's tone was Stern tense
I know what you are suggesting and it
defends me to my core if you do not see
ceasefire implications I will be forced
to end our talk here and now I am a
physician sir I do not endanger my
patients so recklessly I understand
better to leave that theory alone for
now you said that you have always been
here but I I do have to ask have you
ever heard of a place called alagada
there are those that claim you once
lived there that you came from that
Kingdom I have never heard that name
that I can recall but I have lived a
long life perhaps I have forgotten what
nation does that belong to Dr Bradshaw
paused it was his turn to be stumped I'm
not sure do you know who the black Lord
is he couldn't be certain but he thought
he saw scp-049 frown villain a villain
he grumbled under his breath I banish
him from my thoughts that he may never
again enter my sight his gloved hands
clenched into fists and Dr Bradshaw
jotted down another note in the margins
the black Lord he had devoted plenty of
time to everyone else's theories it was
time for one that he had been earnestly
considering doctor it is my opinion that
the pestilence may be connected to
emotional state or heart rate perhaps
both when you treat your patients do you
remove the heart or the amygdala to
address those issues I've noticed heart
removal during a handful of your
procedures
scp-049 enthused however I do not always
remove the heart it varies greatly from
Patient to Patient you see for some the
heart is a crucial part of the infection
the others it impacts the brain others
still deliver all the larger nervous
system that is why it is so difficult to
treat your city it can manifest in
seemingly infinite ways but what about
emotions negative impulses cruelty
selfishness hatred is that a component I
was reviewing your file and you
mentioned in excess of the pestilence in
the home of a wealthy man known for
exploiting his workers and mistreating
his family when you were cross-tested
with scp-682 you remarked that the
pestilence did not only impact humans
suggesting the anomaly was also infected
and you cured your patients well they
don't seem to have a hateful impulse in
their bodies ah eighth can be a disease
the plague doctor took another bite of
food chewing slowly when he swallowed Dr
Bradshaw expected him to elaborate on
this thought but he didn't so Dr
Bradshaw broke the silence the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse the ones that
bring about the end of the world war
famine death and pestilence there have
been stories about them for thousands of
years do you know pestilence personally
are you protecting us from him from the
end of days
scp-049 scoffed I work in science not
stories I intend no disrespect to your
beliefs but surely you'll hear how
absurd that sounds pestilence does not
ride in on a horse it resides in the
body you've lost patience before haven't
you every physician has if what they are
treating is severe it never get any
easier to do so I'm sure have you ever
lost someone special to you though done
something you truly regret perhaps the
pestilence was a manifestation of some
guilt for trauma some shame he could
never truly let go every man has regrets
do you not have those secret shames
doctor Dr Bradshaw changed the subject I
have always wondered this can you see
the misdeeds that someone has done can
you somehow sense the sins of their past
all the harm they have caused why do you
ask
scp-049 cocked his head again are you
afraid I can see something within you he
couldn't explain why but the question
made his stomach turn no he answered it
was a lie will everyone catch the
pestilence eventually as time goes on
the odds do become greater yes but not
everyone is doomed is that it is it time
the passage of time aging Decay The
Great dying you called it so is it dying
itself your cured patients they don't
age they never Decay any more than they
already have death is not natural
scp-049 simply said all things die
eventually Bradshaw argued I have not
died yet scp-049 took a drink of wine
well there was no arguing with that
something else I've been thinking about
is the possibility that the pestilence
is greater than just one thing Dr
Bradshaw began his next Theory doctors
believed at one time that the plague was
caused by an imbalance of the humors in
the body they could recognize the
presence of disease but couldn't
routinely tell them all apart several
different illnesses were referred to as
consumption and leprosy was used as a
catch-all for multiple illnesses as well
clearly you have a knack for knowing
when someone is ill but what if it's
something else something equally bad but
different from what you think it's
cancer or a stroke or a heart condition
there is no one cure except for the
massive transformational work you're
already doing
possible
scp-049 used I would need to consider
that point carefully perhaps you have
unlocked a secret to the pestilence I
missed and again perhaps not if the
pestilence is not death and I do have to
wonder is it the opposite life is a
temporary stay for so many of us less
lucky than you and it seems like you
cure your patience of natural life when
you treat them they become something not
quite dead but not quite living at least
not as they were and illness ailments
hurt all comes as a natural side effect
of being alive so is the great dying
life itself I do not understand the
question and thus I will not respond to
it
scp-049 stated Dr Bradshaw could sense
that the plague doctor was growing
frustrated getting tired of so many
questions that poke to this beliefs his
research and his process is the
pestilence natural or something man-made
humans have created diseases before or
cause them to mutate or worsen them with
chemicals we invent have you heard of
Agent Orange I don't mean to digress but
my point is it's not unheard of for
people to be responsible for a disease I
wonder is the pestilence some something
that developed on its own or is it our
doing a biological weapon a synthesized
virus or artificial mutation created by
other scientists or maybe Dr Bradshaw
paused here referring once more to his
notes is it sin greed lust wrath Pride
Envy gluttony sloth maybe not that
biblical that exact but is it evil the
sort of thing that rots away at a
human's Soul not a plague of the body
but of the very essence and the only way
to cure it is to rip the whole thing out
and start over you seem to have the
answers in mind before you ask me these
questions Dr I will allow you one more
before I take my leave I have found this
whole ordeal quite exhausting Dr Brown
Sean nodded okay just one more is it
something unnatural not man-made not of
nature viruses or bacteria but something
else altogether Something From Another
Dimension another world or the spaces in
between you've been cagey about the
nature of the pestilence for as long as
you have been here and I understand if
you are just being cautious but I can't
help but wonder if there is something
else to the reason you keep so much to
yourself you promise to tell me about
the pestilence but you've barely
responded to most of my questions
accepted as miss my ideas is the
pestilence something that spreads by
thought that lives in the Consciousness
or the subconscious of us all waiting
dormant for something to activate it and
set the sickness free the plague doctor
set down his fork with a clutter I would
respect your scientific curiosity but
there are things I cannot Shadow with
you but my safety for yours for
everyone's do take care you too Dr
Bradshaw stood from his chair collecting
his notes and preparing to leave one
final thing Dr Bradshaw turned back to
face the plague doctor yes those dark
eyes watched him from inside the mask do
you see any of the pestilence in me the
silence that passed between them felt
like an eternity e then
scp-049 spoke no sir I do not but one
day that could change as Dr Bradshaw
made his way back to his office the
words echoed in his mind and he couldn't
make up his mind whether they were
comforting or troubling he had gone into
the meeting with questions but now he
had even more than he started with now
go check out a day in the life of
scp-049 and can scp-049 cure the
pestilence in scp-3008 infinite Ikea for
more of everyone's favorite anomalous
scientist